okay all right here's the next one um
[__] princess on here I immediately know
who this is you do yeah I I immediately
know who this is a no way school days is
on here I immediately know I immediately
know I saw AR Juna I saw school days I
saw made in Abyss don't tell me um I
don't know actually what's the bottom
what's the bottom right one uh that's
the shinkai uh voice of of the dist St
STS or something like that yeah it's the
first shinkai makota short film one of
these is not like the other I know I
know why Pokemon there because the Lugia
movie is [__] movie does slap but not
as good as the not as good as the Mewtwo
one dude come on I mean the first one
yeah yeah the Mewtwo one goes hard yeah
first movie is definitely the best one
is this is this is this shindo I can't
tell no Kevin I think this is Kevin it's
Kevin it's Kevin look look at this
everything aside from [__] school
days has amazing amazing I just wasn't
sure if if Kevin would put his own show
on that Kevin this is Kevin right yeah
of course because literally every show
other than school days is considered to
have some of the best soundtracks in all
of anime yeah it's it's it's definitely
much it's very much hey this is a
composers dude the lukia movie the
soundtrack is [__] insane I don't
remember it's actually really good I was
this the Japanese version cuz in the
English version I can't even I can't
remember sometimes they would redo songs
in English releases well they did that
for the Digimon movie right didn't redo
that right the soundtra probably didn't
oh no in in the Digimon movie Digimon
movie the soundtrack is completely
different yeah they um All Stars Allstar
is a track in the Digimon movie they
they put like Bowling For Soup yeah so
it's like le le Less Than Jake as
well it's actually it's actually sick
that's officially in the Digimon movie
the it is the most late 90s early 2000
soundtrack you'll ever hear I'm I'm I'm
going to say I think they made an
improvement I think it's better I think
the English soundtrack for the digal
movie is better than the original
yeah when that bowling for suit track
comes on bro there must be some there
must be some like uh you know you want
to used to watch a movie and you're like
trying to Pirate a movie as a kid and
then like the the Korean version comes
and you're like what the [__] is this I
imagine maybe there's like a a Japanese
kid somewhere trying to watch Digimon
and then he pulled up like the English
version he starts hearing all star he
like n heau
it Banger holy [__] they had they had
Bare Naked Ladies as well
ladies dude that soundtrack is goed it's
such a good soundtrack okay look look
let's let's break this down all right
obviously Kevin's going to put him made
in Abyss because he made the [__]
soundtrack for it then it could have
been a 3X3 of his entire Kevin's
Greatest Hits but it's not so well I
think I think knowing Kevin I think
Kevin has favorites he has favorites for
sure like madeen Abyss is probably his
his I mean it is his favorite obviously
cuz it's on here um but also Kevin just
giv himself the gold medal
okay you deserve it Kevin you know Akira
has an amazing soundtrack mon no Aruna
also has an amazing soundtrack um what
the [__] is Aruna so adiguna was uh it
was a when was it early 90s I think late
80s something like that uh was it a um
was it a uh what's his name anaki show
I'm trying to
remember what no no no how you
anime 2001 oh wow oh was actually way
after no that was that's the series
right uh yeah yeah it's a series one
type movie um perhaps is it a movie or
no I think it's a series the one oh
really yeah it's the director's cut yeah
sh is it is it
Arno 2001 what is that ad 01 what that
[__] scroll down scroll down scroll
down for a
second uh no it's
not okay anyway I I've I haven't seen
all of it I've seen clips from it but
it's it was that well let's let's look
at the M yep cuz I actually don't
remember Juna adosi is an ordinary
Japanese school girl Conor's like I
sleep who possesses a childlike
curiosity and a strong admiration
towards nature one day while on a trip
with her boyfriend Jun dies from a
motorcycle accident however she's given
a chance to live by an individual named
Chris Hawkin well very English name all
he offers her powers that makes her the
Avatar of time in exchange she must
fight to protect the Earth from evil
force okay so it's like a it's like a
early 2000s uh like
sci-fi but I do know for a fact though
that I have I have when I've talked to
Kevin about like anime music he does
bring up aduna a lot and he says that
that this series is the reason why he
started making music and why he wanted
to make music for anime I hope it is cuz
it's scored as 6.78 on my anime so you
got have a good reason for liking
that but he but according to Kevin he's
like aduna has one of the best
soundtracks that he's ever heard in in
all of anime yeah cuz I know I think
what immediately gave this away from me
just immediately seeing this is number
one a lot of these are films and films
normally have you know are more
especially if you're a composer you know
you're allowed to have I
guess sometimes it's more impactful to
be able to score like music for certain
like for like a feature film whereas for
certain like anime series you know you
kind of just have to make certain tracks
not knowing what final scene they're
going to be used in and that just means
a lot of film scores end up being very
very memorable and very very impactful
um I have talked to him about
Teran resident Zan no Tera as well what
an amazing soundtrack that is his
favorite soundtrack of all time in terms
of anime and it is mine as well it's one
of my favor actually to be fair it does
say something because I actually don't
remember much about the show but I do
remember that the songs always very
compelling it was the Icelandic infused
music yeah do like the terrorism though
that was fun too nothing nothing matches
terrorism more than Icelandic music do
you know I don't know if we I don't know
if we need to cut this you know do you
know something uh interesting about
Teran resonance what so okay so the show
is obviously about a group a group of
terrorists right yeah so when this was
airing there I can't remember if it was
their ninth or 11th episode got delayed
I do remember this happening yeah yeah
do you know what date it aired on 911
yes oh my
god really yeah holy [__] that was I'm
like when that why it got delayed or it
pushed it back to like I can't remember
I just remember guys hold hold hold on
you know what be really funny we had
such a funny
moment someone in the boardroom was just
like we can make something really we can
send a message with this we can make
something really funny happen right now
but uh no but to me I still think that I
still really really [__] like Zano
Tera yeah it's a good shot yeah I
remember when it came out everyone was
talking about it and it was really I me
it just kind of disappeared after that
year I think a lot of people uh were not
happy with the plot and the characters
but um I I don't know something about
the feeling that show gives is there has
been very very few shows and a lot of
this is to do with the soundtrack but a
lot of this just a lot of individual
scenes as well I don't fully remember
what the plot was but I know that they
were terrorists and they had a a solid
reason hope so that's it that's all I
remember but I I also remember being
like ah okay we we did terrorism and uh
and now it's over and now the show's
over it's like okay cool guys terrorism
is over guys it's like uh I I I remember
watching it feel like it should have
been longer it was what 12 episodes
right yeah it was 12 episodes cuz you
know nowadays we're starting to get some
24s popping up and even longer that was
I think when this came out it was there
was only 12 episode animes coming out
does Kevin have any reasons for why he
put these on or no no reason I mean I I
mean I guess it's self I can pretty much
guess which with most I just want to
know why he put school days on there cuz
I'd love to shake his
hand just because uh let's just say
Kevin didn't put it Kevin didn't put it
on there for the [__] soundtrack that
he was probably grinning going like I
can do a cheeky move here put school
days on my that's my Kevin is that
Kevin sounds like a brexit Geer go get
in I just wa school days watch Kevin
Kevin you realize now that you are one
of the
most respected you know staff members in
the anime industry right now especially
in composers you know fan and Industry
alike what the [__] is school days for
like doing on here Kevin what is it
doing on here I mean my respect went up
for you know well deserved I would say I
don't want to hear if I didn't already
love you I love you even more now I
don't want to be listening to [__] M
and abys having the existential crisis
of my life definitely did this for me
and then in the back of my mind I'm like
you know school days played a part in
making this you know you know you're
talking like you're talking like anime
crators of the most well adjusted views
on most thing go God come on